in this country the biden administration
says it will wait for the cdc's guidance
on whether to appeal a judge's ruling
that struck down mass mandates on
airplanes and public transit so far the
cdc hasn't given any guidance on that
the judge's decision has caused
uncertainty especially among the most
vulnerable to covid errol barnett is at
reagan national airport outside of
washington errol good morning
hey there vlad good morning one thing to
keep in mind here is that the original
mask mandate was set to expire in 13
days anyway so even if the cdc made a
new determination and the department of
justice appealed the florida federal
judge's decision it would only extend
the rule by a matter of days and while
yes certainly many are excited to see
the end of this rule cbs news is also
finding others are now having to make
difficult decisions and are upset to see
the end of the mass mandate
in public transportation hubs across the
country travelers now have the option to
go mask-less uber and lyft joined all
u.s airlines and amtrak saying masks are
now optional
while cities like philadelphia and new
york say the mandate will remain in
place i think it should be up to what
the person wants i will probably wear it
until i get on the plane and when i sit
in my seat i will take it off president
biden carefully weighed in tuesday
mr president should people continue to
wear masks on planes
that's up to them
ganette abate is an uber driver in the
d.c area thrilled to learn the rideshare
service dropped its requirement i just
want to feel free and breathe freely
feel very safe to not wear a mask still
the 47 percent spike in covert cases in
just the last 14 days has some high-risk
travelers on edge i'm concerned i'm
especially concerned about who i'll sit
next to and if they'll be
willing to wear a mask gretchen mew says
one of seven million americans who are
immuno-compromised
but despite the risks musa is going to
stick with her plans to visit her
grandparents who are both in their 90s
in california i needed to weigh whether
if i didn't go see them which might be
the safer choice for my physical health
how much regret i would have later in
life if uh i go through my life knowing
that i wasn't able to be there for them
it's a tough choice and we should note
the cdc still recommends mass use while
traveling on aircraft but now all the
major airlines have to decide what to do
about all of those passengers banned for
failure to comply with this federal rule
for united airlines that's about a
thousand people it tells cbs news it
will decide if those folks can get back
on board gail on a case-by-case basis
it is an interesting question errol
thank you very much